a tutorial on probability attorneys
thanks about good morning everyone so my
goal today is to come from the other
side from the data base side of this
workshop so I'm going to give a very
brief introduction of what databases are
and then talk about probabilistic
databases so why probabilistic databases
because we want to capture uncertainties
in the database and this is done by
associating a probability to every
topple in the database with the meaning
that that topper might be present or
might be absent and the the the
challenge the the entire focus on
probabilistic databases is how to
evaluate queries how to compute queries
this is also related to statistical
relational models that were developed in
the AI community where the goal was to
represent and to perform live inferences
in first order logic as opposed to in a
grounded model and it turns out that the
these two developments they were
essentially parallel to each other
they've kind of looked for the same
solutions to the general problem of
doing inference not at the grounded
level but at the first order logic
higher order representation of the model
and I'd like to advertise two sources
for probability databases one is the
this book joint with Dan Alton oh and
the Chris Rea and Christopher [ __ ] and
then there is an upcoming survey paper
with given den Broek who sit somewhere
here that hopefully will come up soon so
a crash course in relational databases
and databases we represent data in
relations here we have a relation of
smokers and the relation of friends the
schema of the relational database is
fixed smoker has two attributes friends
has two attributes and the database is
large red for me means large and I'll
come back to that later
queries and databases our first order
first order sentence first of the
formulas this query here returns all old
friends of smokers from 2009 and that is
a particular answer on this database I
will represent queries in blue they are
typically fixed and not very big most in
most of this talk I'm going to be
interested in boolean queries which are
sentences these are closed formulas in
that case a query is either true or is
false
another matter of terminology a
conjunctive query is a query that has
only exist answer quantifiers and
conjunctions a union of conjunctive
queries has only existence of
quantifiers conjunctions and
disjunctions and I will refer sometimes
to these disturbes
alternatively and databases were
interested in constraints their
practical purpose is different from
queries constraints are assertions that
we claimed to hold on the database for
for the purpose of this talk there will
be no distinction constraint are just
another type of off sentences they are
typically universally quantified so this
constraint says that every smoker in
2010 with a friend of Bob and it happens
to be true on this database okay so that
is my crash background in relational
databases now let's see what a
probabilistic database is it's a
standard relational database where every
tuple is a random event is a
probabilistic event it might be present
or it might be absent we annotate we add
another attribute and annotates are
toppled with a probability of being
present or absent present absence is to
enforce yeah like true are true and
forth
what
so if probability is 1 then say stopper
is always present with the probability 0
you can simply remove it and forget
about it it's never there yes and this
is close to what the assumption yes
defining probability databases as
probability models of spatial databases
that sounds difficult but sounds like
the thing might want it
is this a choice that's exactly how I
imagined them so let me show you how I
imagined them so I imagined them exactly
as a set is a probability distribution
on possible database instances this
particular probabilistic database
defines a probability distribution where
the outcomes are all the subsets of this
relation that's exactly what Dan was
hinting at this is one possible outcome
and its probability is P 1 times P 2
times P 3 here is another one
this probability is 1 minus P 1 because
the first Apple is missing and so on
there are eight possible outcomes and
they have each has a probability and the
sum of these probabilities of course is
1 this is a probability space and the C
the probability of every word is
obtained by simply assuming that the
tuples are included in that world
independently with a probability given
in the table any questions about the
model of a probability database
more complicated measures and might've
chosen so it's is this the only type of
model that it's under consideration
mostly in the literature people consider
more more letters people never
considered slightly more complex
measures but I will have one slide to
talk about much richer model that can be
captured in this model easily using
conditioned by conditioning on the
constraint that's a high level idea into
billion compute the semantics in this
way but it doesn't require that the
parameterization of the model it's at
okay the basic question that we may
address is given a query what is the
probability that this query is true in a
randomly chosen world which is the sum
of the probabilities of all the world
where the query is true and I'm going to
use the I mean going to I'm interested
in the complexity of computing this
probability notice that we don't want to
sum up over all the possible world
because they are exponentially many and
the size of the database if it have 1
million tuples this is 2 to the power 1
million way too big and I'm interested
in the complexity of computing this
probability as a function of the size of
the probabilistic database of the number
of tuples and this is called data
complexity using a terminology
introduced by var D 1980 throughout the
talk read a minty input this is variable
while blue is fixed every query defines
another another problem computer
computes a probability of South query on
input databases D so this is the model
any questions about the model okay so
this is the outline of my the rest of
the talk I'm going to connect
probability databases to model counting
and weighted modern counting then I'm
going to talk about the main result in
probability databases and relates this
to to a standard our goal is for model
counting over propositional boolean
formulas and then I will conclude and
mention some open problems modern
accounting is one of the way studied
problems in complexity given a
propositional boolean formula the
problem is to compute the number of
models the number of two's assignments
of this form life for example if this is
a boolean formula here how do you
compute how many to use assignments
there are I don't know of any better way
and I think nobody knows then to
essentially enumerate all through the
side
see how many of them are true and then
returned that number which is for
valiant proved in 1979 that this problem
is short be hard even if the input are
restricted to two CNF a variant is to
compute a probability of a boolean or
propositional boolean formula here every
boolean variable is associated with a
number between 0 and 1 which is a
probability and the question is given F
and these numbers what is the
probability that the formula is true if
each propositional boolean variable is
set independently to true or false
according to its probability in example
we look at the assignments where this
formula is true and teach assignment has
a probability that is easily computed
assuming these wherever's are
independent this assignment has
probability 1 minus P 1 P 2 P 3 we add
them up and artis a result religious
generalizes model counting because if
all probabilities are 1/2 then the
probability of the formula is a model
count by 2 to the N the opposite doesn't
hold there are you can come up easily
with classes of boolean formulas for
which the model counting problem is easy
with in polynomial time but the
probability computation problem is short
behold okay so what are well how do
people compute the probability of
boolean formulas the standard algorithm
is based on the DPL full search and this
I took from a very nice survey by kamesh
severable and Salman from 2009 so these
are Gordon's work as follows they are
essentially the same skeleton as
algorithm used in sad solvers they
perform three kind of actions they they
can choose a propositional boolean
variable X and then the number of models
of F is a number of models of the
formula where that
variable is false plus a number of
models of the formula where that
variable is set to true this is one
possibility the other action that they
do they might store since it is odd and
use it later if they encounter the same
the same formula again this is called
cashing and finally they could identify
that the formula is consists of two sets
of clauses
it's a conjunction of two sets of
process that do not share any
propositional boolean variables so if no
boolean variable occurs both in F 1 and
F 2 then the number of models of the
conjunction is the product of the number
of models and that simplifies the
computation of the model counting
computation quite a lot so this is a
state-of-the-art essentially I should
say most modern counting systems they
are based on this basic dpla procedure
yes and this and this in this framework
all the bull and all a propositional
boolean variables are considered
independent I will come back to this I
have one slide on this on this topic
which is also a sixth and answer
question these days like close learning
etcetera has it penetrated the model
counting as far as I know not there are
new developments like STDs which STDs
sentential decision diagrams introduced
by another vision and I have just one
one little thing to say about them
okay so this is propositional model
counting what we need is actually
slightly different we need we are in a
setting in which the boolean formula is
defined implicitly by a first-order
sentence so we have a first-order
sentence or query and we have a fixed
domain domain I call it Delta think of
this as all the constants that occur in
your database or that you are willing to
use in your database now every ground
adam ground atom is a relational symbol
followed by constants from that domain
every ground atom we associated with a
propositional boolean variable which can
be true or false indicating where the
result ground atom is in the possible
world or not that is the intuition the
lineage of the query on this domain is
defined inductively on the structure of
the query and is a propositional boolean
formula that essentially says when the
query is true on a possible world of
defined over the domain Delta for
example if the query is a conjunction
then this is a conjunction of the two
lineages Universal quantifiers become
conjunctions over the domain these
essential quantifiers become these
junctions over the domain and when we
reach a ground atom then we that is the
actual boolean formula that we return a
simple example this is the constraint
says that every student is a person and
if we have a domain of size n then this
expands into a conjunction of size n
each saying that student I implies that
implies personal PI so again this
boolean formula is called as a lineage
or provenance or in a is called a
grounding of sentence Q over the domain
Delta
okay now if we have a concrete database
then the the lineage or them the
grounding over of a query of of the
database is obtained by grounding it
over the domain of the database and then
looking at which tuples are missing from
the database and those boolean variables
are set to false it's just a minor tweak
to ensure that the topper set are not
present in your database are a priori
set set to false so this is called again
the provenance or the grounding of of
cue but it's easy to see that if if we
are given probabilities for every for
every topper in a database they
correspond to probabilities of the
propositional boolean variables
associated to those Stoppers and in that
situation the the probability of the
boolean formula of the lineage is
exactly the same as a probability of
sequere
defined in terms of possible words the
signature is for will to zero everything
not here it's probability zero and that
I said this is why we needed in this
lineage to set two to four door that
operates with all the blue a very
bizarre correspond to top is not present
at the database
so that the question that we are going
to address in this talk the remaining of
the talk is fixed query which is a
first-order sentence and we want to
understand we want to study the
complexity of computing the probability
of the query over a an input database T
which is the same as a problem of
computing the probability of the lineage
with the propositional boolean formula
obtained from Q and the database D as a
side question I'm also interested in the
the complexity or the in the runtime of
a very efficient dll based algorithm
that runs on the grounding on the
lineage of the query over the database T
how does this runtime behave as a
function of the input database team
there any questions about problem
statement produces qts expert can be
exponentially the compacted presentation
here before right fq d is always
polynomial I should have mentioned this
you go back the formula is fixed so if
you look at what happens here the size
of this formula will increase by the
size of the domain every time you are
eliminating a quantifier so it's the
data complexity gain that saves us and
the other complexity
probably approximately correct these
queries but yes people are interested in
approximations I don't have anything to
say in this talk
Wolfgang cutter bar later this this
morning we'll talk about approximations
and least I get to infinity afternoon
we'll talk about approximations okay so
before I move on I want to find out a
clarify the issue with core about
correlations so in probabilistic data
databases a model looks very simple all
the tuples are independent in the real
life we have rich rich correlations
between between events one popular model
that captures captured these
correlations I mean there are multiple
such models Markov logic networks
introduced by Domingues and Richardson
we heard about about blog yesterday that
also captured correlations and in these
systems correlations are often captured
using soft constraints so for example in
Markov logic networks you can say
typically it takes is a spoke around is
friends with Y then typically wiseass
poker - and the weight we associate here
is 2.3 talk before what queries and
constraints and you never say what would
happen if you had quiz n constraints if
you have queries and constraints I think
of her constraint as just another
sentence so if you want to check if it
is limiting the set of possible worlds
right right so I could have imagined
even before I go to any of these just in
a purely database database set up some
interesting cool evaluation model or
given a given constraint exactly so that
is that is definitely a good go
sensibility completely within our
framework because it's a conditional
probability and you get exactly the
arrive with the format right here this
is what you're interested in you are
interested in the the conditional
probability of the query given some
constraint gamma it's just just a ratio
of two probabilities
so to finish my example the G systems
like blog and Markov logic networks they
allow you to specify soft constraints
now blog also allows you to increase the
size of the domain something that I
don't know how to capture in
probabilistic databases but soft
constraints they turn out to be easily
captured in probabilistic databases by
adding one new relational symbol for
every soft constraint making that a tap
an independent relation and then
constructing some particular constraint
which needs to be constructed
assertively simple comes from these soft
constraints and then the the probability
over this rich space over the Markov
logic Network space is equal to the
conditional probability conditioned on
this constraint so I'm going to skip the
details I have actually if you are
interested I can talk to you about the
details of this translation it's very
simple and this allows us to focus
entirely on query evaluation over top
and independent databases and assume
that constraint are captured through
this translation okay so now let me dig
into the complexity of the query
evaluation problem and I will start with
a brief background on how query
evaluation proceeds in relational
databases in the relational databases
every query is first converted into a
query plan the query plan consists of
operators these are the five five
standard operators in query plans
selections projections join Union and
difference and the query optimizer
considered alternative query plans for
evaluating a given query over a database
for example this query here returns a
set of values G for which G
there exists an X and there is the Y and
the revista you you has to be the
constant 1 2 3 such that this this
formula is satisfied a database engine
might decide to first join a S&T on Y
then select all those entries where u is
1 2 3 joins the result with X and
finally project only on the variability
and this is one very plan so let's see
what what probabilistic database
involves
what kind of computations do we need to
do if the database is probabilistic as
opposed to deterministic and I have here
a simple example so this is a boolean
query it checks if it is there exists x
and y such that R of X and s of X when X
Y are true and like and like in the
logic programming like a prologue or
data log this notation actually means
existential quantifiers and conjunctions
so all a coma means conjunction and
every variable that is not occurrence
ahead it exists an surely quantified
here is our probabilistic database the
question is what is the probability of
this query being true over the possible
words of the database now if this were a
deterministic database if this very
deterministic then obviously the query
is true because I can satisfy it by
setting X to a a one and setting y to be
one and these two satisfy the query but
the database is probabilistic so I need
to reason about events one way to
satisfy the query is to have one of
these two tuples at the database here is
a probability and have this tuple in the
database and that is the probability
that the query satisfied by by by x
equals a 1 and B either be 1 and and why
are there B 1 or B 2 there is a second
way
we can satisfy it using one of these
three and a two and here is the
probability and it turns out that these
two ways to satisfy Q are independent so
the probability of the query is this
expression which looks big but it's
actually if you think about this it is
polynomial in the size of of the input
database actually it's actually linear
in the size of the input database so one
can compute the probability of this
particular query in polynomial time in
the size of the database team so a
definition we call will let me let me
get back there what we want to do we
want to modify the query plant that our
traditional and database systems we want
to modify them to manipulate
probabilities to do these kind of
computations to multiply and and do the
probability manipulations to compute the
output of of the query so it turns out
that we can do this to some extent but
we have to be careful there are some
surprises and here is a surprise if you
run this query in Postgres or in any
database system it will produce a query
plan that looks like this which will
join R and s obtain up the result and
then project out essentially check if
the result is non-empty now if you
extend here the operators with explicit
manipulations of probabilities then what
you get is a following the joint will
multiply them and the duplicate
elimination will assume that they're
independent and there is out is wrong
the result is wrong because during
duplicate elimination independents field
whether we turns out this is just an
artifact of the plan that we have chosen
we could have chosen a different query
plan
and you can imagine modifying the
optimizer of a probability database
system to be aware of these correlations
this different query plan removes the
extra variable Y early it does this
projection early and now the
probabilities look right because once we
remove the the extra variable for the
the probability for every value X namely
for a 1 and for a - they are the right
expressions and now after we do the
joint and duplicate elimination we get
the right other so this is interesting
some query semantics I mean now that I
have notice now that matters quantities
I should really thinking of how I do
this evaluation in Beck semantics colors
and in the set semantics so if you do
back semantics at some point you still
need to do duplicate elimination because
the the query even in numbers ok so the
statement I want to make here it's
actually much more limited I want to say
let's modify the operators in a simple
way to joint will multiply probabilities
and duplicate elimination will assume
that events are independent and in that
case if that if these are the only
changes that you're making even if you
want to use back semantics you still
need to do duplicate you need to do
handle you think you still need to be
aware of the correlations between the
toppers that might violate these
assumptions
so this was actually this is a surprise
to database systems people because they
think objects to query such as being
equivalent but once you extend them with
manipulate explicit manipulations of
probabilities then they are no longer
equivalent and you need to choose the
right one good so we say that a query
plan for a query queue is safe it's not
a good name but that's what we're stuck
with it it's safe if it computes a
probabilities correcting correctly the
the plan on the left was not safe the
plan of the right was safe and we say
that the query is safe if it has a safe
plan now it turns out that in zài
literature computing a query queue like
this by essentially looking at the first
order expression and deciding a subtle
about how to manipulate probabilities
this is called lifted inference lifted
to appearance is a slightly more general
term it often uses it already also
refers to the ability to use symmetries
something that done is going to talk
about tomorrow and we heard the talk
yesterday about exploiting symmetries in
the probability space this is not what
I'm going to do in this talk so I only
have one slide to talk about symmetries
later so in terms of terminology saying
that a query is safe is the same as
saying except that the query is liftable
that it can be computed using the first
order expression so it's every query
easy to compute is every query
computable in polynomial time of course
not
here is one example it's a simplest
simplest example of a query that is not
computable in polynomial time it checks
if that exists x and y such that exist
and our Y is in T and X Y are in s if
you try to compute a query using this
plan if you're really a database system
you will try one or is this plan or the
other one it's wrong it will not compute
the probabilities correctly
and it's not very surprising it turns
out that computing the probability of
this query over a an input database is
shortly hard in the size of the input
database D
so that is that is a state of query
evaluation and database and I will dig
into this deeper for some queries we
have a safe plan and which means we can
compute this query very efficiently we
can even push this computation into the
existing engine we use the operators
that joins the duplicate elimination the
indexes all the optimizations that exist
already for other queries like this one
there is no way we can do this and
actually they are provably hard but it
turns out that even these queries we can
say something interesting about them for
example work on cutter power he will
tell you that even this plan also it's
wrong it's guaranteed to return an upper
bound on the true probability and this
is a general principle it's very
interesting we can use it for example to
compute a proposal distribution if you
are really using this assay as a general
technique and an MCMC system we used it
in a different way to design an MC
approach to compute unsafe queries by by
something only some of the tables and
I'm not going to talk about this today
good so some queries are easy some
queries are hard which which ones are
easy and which ones are hard I'm going
to give you an answer
I need a definition fix a query a query
expression for every variable X let's
define the atoms of X to be old all the
atoms or the literals that contains a
variable X we call Q hierarchical for
any two variables x and y either the set
of atoms of X is a subset of Y or vice
versa or they are disjoint
that is a definition of a hierarchical
query for example this query here the
conjunction of R and s is hierarchical
because the the set of atoms where X
occurs is aren't s the set of atoms
where Y or Z occurs are only R or only s
and this forms a hierarchical collection
of three sets or friend h0 from the
previous slide which was Sharpie heart
is not hierarchical because x contains R
and s Y contains s and T and these two
sets overlap without one being contained
in the other and it turns out that
hierarchical queries are exactly the
separation between easy and hard queries
but only for a very restricted class of
queries so when going to restrict or
conjunctive queries so only conjunctions
and agrees denture quantifiers and
moreover they will be non repeating
there is no good term for this sometimes
you call them conjunctive queries
without self joins I've also seen the
term simpler conjunctive queries with
what this means is that all the that
every relational symbol is allowed to
occur only once we cannot reuse the same
relational symbol good so this is a
query language is a very restricted
query language that we consider and for
this query language the following
theorem holds if the query is
hierarchical then it's in polynomial
time and if it is not hierarchical then
it is probably sharply hard in C input
database this is a statement of
conjunctive queries but by duality it
also holds for clauses for single
clauses which are dysfunctions of
literature until you knew they are
universally quantified
so somebody so far for non-repeating
conjunctive queries or non repeating
clauses they are in P time if they're
hierarchical and there shall be heart if
they are not revin if you look at it
from a parametrized complexity point of
view there's something to interpolate
between these two things will not be
bounded three which what happens fill
the polity with square roots
I'm trying to remember what the
parameterized complexity is for
conjunctive queries it depends on their
three ways but hierarchical conjunctive
where they have a small for arbitrary
code Zak W on time right but these are
three which give you the exponent
Japanese yeah by the bees are
hierarchical queries and they are a they
are a cyclic I'm pretty sure they're the
Alpha is cyclic so the exponent will be
1 so the the which would kind of be some
kind of interpolation between these two
zeroes yeah butBut you'reyou're being
hit by by the sharp from the size of the
data right it's a good observation but I
don't have anything to say about it
actually is bounded but I think that's a
different difference they're good so
that was a simple it's a small dichotomy
theorem now let me show you the big idea
dichotomy theorem which is interesting
especially on the EG side on the
polynomial time side and it's
interesting because all queries that you
can compute in polynomial time in a much
richer language you can compute them
using these rules and angle I will go
one minute over them negation is trivial
the probability of a negation is 1 minus
P of Q if the query is a conjunction or
a disjunction of two sentences then you
first check if these two sentences toge
don't share any relational symbols and
if they don't share any relational
symbol since they are independent and we
apply a trivial rule something similar
holds for extension or Universal
quantifiers you need to check some
syntactic property of how this variable
G is using you to ensure that if you
substitute the variable G with different
constants from the domain then the
resulting queries are independent and
then you can eliminate a quantifier
using one of these two for
these are kind of straightforward rules
that have immediate interpretation in
the ground that world if you look at the
propositional boolean formulas that
correspond to the lineage of the query
given by the lineage of the query the
last two rules are surprising so to get
to compute all queries that are in
polynomial time you need to use
inclusion exclusion and you need to use
a very interesting form of the inclusion
exclusion I will show you examples so I
want to make a statement of when these
rules are complete and for that I'm
going to introduce definition which is
what I need it's not going to be
complete for its entire personal logic
but it's going to be complete for
interesting fragments let me call it
first-order sentence you need if or
negations occur only on the atoms and
for every symbol are either it is only
positive all occurrences of or are
positive or all occurrences of are
negated so and f-u-n is a restriction of
birth or death first-order sentences to
unit formulas okay so here is a theorem
that we have if you further a straight
only one type of quantifier either only
Universal quantifier or only exists
under quantifiers then if the rule
succeed then they will compute acquire
in polynomial time you apply these rules
but you need to check the syntactic
condition before you can apply a rule at
some point you might reach a state may
reach a query for which none of the
rules satisfy the syntactic condition
that are required to apply that rule and
in that case the rules do not succeed
ya know what's the criterion for
termination and food
for determination as you apply the rules
eventually you reach ground atoms I
should have mentioned this yeah let me
go back as important so you apply these
through starting from the original
sentence eventually because you're
substituting variables with constants
from the domains eventually you reach
ground atoms when you reach current out
ground atom then the probability of that
ground autumn is you look it up in the
database if you don't if you cannot do
independent projection exactly that's
exactly when you do get get stuck when
you cannot do independent projection
okay so the dichotomy theorem says that
for these languages which are still
restricted they are not a full portrait
or logic but they are they're just one
once we know the query is either a
polynomial time we said we'll succeed if
you apply the roots and get stuck then
we have a promise we have a proof that
the query is sharpy hard in the size of
the database so this language that's not
very familiar but it's essentially
unions of conjunctive queries if you
think about a sentence here all the
negated occurrences of relational
symbols you can replace them with a
positive relational symbol where you
modify the probabilities from P to 1
minus P there are no quantifiers because
what's the point of putting the for all
star in front of three or four yeah this
might be a poor choice of notation but
what I mean here is first-order logic I
think actually I saw this notation in
one of your papers
okay so it's oh maybe maybe with this
without it for you the way you present
it right yeah I I agree it's not no it's
not a quality but I mean it's 1/4 of the
logic restricted to universal
quantifiers and and you need numerator
appearing accenture more simply
structured networks I'm wondering
whether it's typical that queries
against the original Markov logic
Network end up being unique or not very
it's actually an important of an
important observation if you start from
an arbitrary mark of arbitrary from one
of the Markov logic networks that you
find in a research paper and do the
translation that I briefly mentioned on
a slide the resulting queries are
typically not unit you can try to apply
the rules and if you're lucky you might
succeed probably or not lucky and in
that case we don't offer you an an
immediate solution we offer you an
understanding of where which queries are
hard and which are not hard and that is
where we are now I have ideas on how to
exploit the subclass of queries that are
easy in order to compute hard queries
but that's not something I going to talk
in this talk pork and we'll briefly
mentioned that but that's beyond my goal
so I want to show you a little bit the
interesting part which is this how do we
compute queries when they are easy and
I'm going to start by showing this to
you on a very simple conjunctive query
this checks if there exists x and y such
that x of s and y and R of Y and also
there exists two different x and y
possibly different x and y for which s
and t are
it's a conjunctive query it is
disconnected in the sense that it is a
conjunction of two boolean conjunctive
queries we check separately for this
query and separately for that query we
cannot apply a standard join we cannot
multiply the probabilities of Q 1 and Q
2 because the symbol s occurs in both of
them
so these are correlated probabilistic
events so we cannot apply an independent
joint however what we can do here we can
apply the inclusion exclusion formula
which is a not very standard inclusion
exclusion formula it expresses a
probability of the conjunction as a sum
of the two probabilities minus the
probability of the disjunction kind of
the dual of the one that you usually use
a little bit more surprising is that we
apply the same kind of move for a union
of conjunctive queries the needs of
conjunctive pharisee are usually unions
of expressions like these but we insist
that you convert them into CNF so to
expose a disjunction and then you up you
apply you use the inclusion exclusion
formula of this kind to get back a
disjunction so whatever we have we
gained we started from a from a query
that can avoid consists of the
conjunction of Q 1 Q 2 now have their
disjunction so what I did advantage the
advantage is that the existential
quantifier that we had implicitly here
commute with or it does not commute with
and I cannot substitute y 1 and y 2 with
the same variable but in the disjunction
I can substitute them with the same
variable Y because the central
quantifier is the same as a disjunction
now the syntactic precondition required
for an independent project are met and
what we can do is we can compute the
probability of their disjunction as
using this huge formula here it is 1
minus a probability of 1 minus Sigma
probability of set of the same query for
where Y is substituted with some
constant as a domain the other two k1
and k2 they are they are easy we have
seen it's essentially q1 before
and q2 is similar so we can compute the
probability of this query in an
interesting way although we started with
a conjunctive query we are forced to end
up with the Union of conjunctive queries
that is one of the surprises of trying
to compute probabilities over the first
order sentence you are forced to use to
move out of conjunctive queries into
units and I had here as a same example
oh and the run time is of course
polynomial I had here the same example
for the dual the dual is a single clause
universally quantified now it's exactly
the same expression is before but and is
it placed with or existence of
quantifiers it pays with universal
quantifiers here - it's a CNF formula
it's usually a big conjunction of
clauses but I'm forcing you to think of
it as a disjunction of two CNF formulas
and on this disjunction you would apply
it now the standard inclusion exclusion
formula and makes the same progress as
before
any questions about this example okay so
this is a query for which the roots work
here are a set of queries for the roots
to not work we call them HK h 0 was a
query that we saw before and these are
again conger sorry
these are now constraint so they are
universally quantified so I'm dropping
the universal quantifier here and it
turns out each of these each of these
queries is sharpy hard
let me read one of you one one of them
to you here we we essentially join R of
X with as of x and y then with the same
symbol as one we join X Y with s2 of X Y
then with the same symbol as 2 we join
it with a 3 of X the same X Y and
finally s3 is joined with T but now the
this variable Y that occurs in both
atoms occurs on the second position
while X here occurs in the first
position
that causes this query to be hard it's
very interesting on the other hand if
you if you drop any of these clauses or
in the dual in the conjunctive query for
drop on any of the contract in conjunct
of the counter conjunctive queries then
the remaining query is e and this is
because you have separated this left
part from the right part and the query
becomes easy ok so a summary so far for
the simple case of non repeating
conjunctive queries the separation into
P time or sharpy heart was given by a
hierarchical or non hierarchical queries
for this this richer languages for which
I have the wrong notation essentially
quantified or universally quantified
unit first order logic the separation is
given by the fact that they will succeed
or or they don't succeed and we don't
know the query complexity of deciding
between these two cases we know that is
decidable
we given a query I'd like to know if it
falls here or fourth Porter
so that was that is the the dichotomy
result on the complexity of the queries
the last question I want to address is
what if we follow the more traditional
approach we take the query we take the
database we grant a query to obtain this
large boolean formula the lineage is
large but it's only polynomially large
in the size of the database and then run
a traditional DP ll based algorithm how
far do we get how fast can the best
algorithm on this boolean formula now to
honor to answer this question we use an
observation by Huang and Darvish who
observed that any dll based algorithm
that uses whatever heuristics for
choosing the variable orders or deciding
when to do caching or with deciding on
when to do components any the trace of
any such algorithm is a graph called the
decision DN enough the trace is
essentially the operations that these
are giris performs very blessed
structured in in a in a graph I don't
have a good definition for it let me
define a DNF in the name explained it's
a little bit better
edie a decision DD Endon f is a rooted
dag where every internal node is either
a decision node it checks the decides
which x bulent propositional boolean
variable and has two children the label
0 or 1 or it is a conjunction which has
a property that all the variables
occurring in the left dag and with the
variables occurring at the right tag are
disjoint they're disjoint sets of
variables the sink node the leaf nodes
they are labeled with 0 or 1
and it needs to satisfy two properties
first of all the the aunt knows must
have disjoint sets of variables on the
left and on the right and the second
property is at every path from the root
to some sync node must visit every
variable at most once if you think about
the DPLA based algorithm this is this
captures what they compute if they
decide to to compute a probability of a
boolean formula as a product of two
probabilities because these two boolean
formulas are are independent then you
represented with an end node when they
do a Shannon expansion you represented
with an X node and that's how you get
from the DPL our God has been to the
decision gideon an effort good Prime
Minister to Stacey result I have a I
need to introduce the notation these
were the clauses that we used for the
query HK that long query that I claimed
HRP hard now instead of taking their
conjunction to obtain the query HK I'm
going to use some arbitrarily boolean
monotone boolean formula in k plus 1
variables called MD and I'm going to
construct a query obtained by plugging
in these clauses for the variable Z 0 up
to TK so any such Budin formula gives me
a different query that is kind of a
combination of C's HK eyes so for
example if I just take their conjunction
then the square is exactly HK and it's
hard but I'm going to take more
interesting combinations ok so here is
the theorem I wanted to share with you
so take any such boolean function of the
queries HK I first of all any decision
DD and an F for the lineage of this
query over a domain of size and it's
probably exponentially large
for any such query if you ground it and
compute and use the DPLA based algorithm
is going to take exponential amount of
time the second part is a little bit
more subtle for some queries their
complexity is hard for other queries
they can be computed in polynomial time
and the separation is done by the mobis
function on the on the implica it's
actually the implicants lot lattice of
two I'm going to skip that part but I'm
going to show you how they include the
power of the inclusion exclusion formula
is that's going to be my last technical
slide so the example is here we have the
four queries that form a ch3 and I have
here a DNF expression where a massage is
query somehow and to obtain a larger
query called QW to compute this
probability we apply the inclusion
exclusion formula we hand a three terms
so we need to get 7x7 terms in the
inclusion exclusion formula here they
are
this one here contains all these three
ages so this we cannot compute this this
is sharpie Hart
I mean we can compute it of course but
it will be an exponential cost it shall
be hard and it's obtained by by joining
these the first in the third month the
last term of the inclusion exclusion
formula is obtained by joining or three
of them this order shall be hard we
cannot compute it but they are equal so
they cancel out and since they cancel
out we don't need to compute them and
therefore the queries in polynomial time
however add any DPL based algorithm the
exponential time if you run it on the
expansion of this query good so I know I
only have like two minutes so I'm going
to skip the moobus part
so let me summarize so we have a
separation of the complexity of
computing the query query of a
probability databases for two languages
not for the entire further adue logic
and for a much more restricted class of
queries we can prove that any dpla based
algorithms expansion time yet for some
queries in this class the probability
can be computed the polynomial time
others are sharpie hard and we know
exactly which one which ones followed
where okay I'm going to spend one minute
with a summary slide and then I'm going
to skip say really future work so
imagine these are all the queries in
your your language and they're typically
shortly hard now
what I've shown you today is that some
are actually in polynomial time like
this QW and many many more and others
are are hard it turns out that we
understand quite well the complexity of
the lineage that you obtain by grounding
these queries we have a complete
characterization of which queries have a
lineage that is elite ones propositional
boolean formula beyond that we have a
complete characterization of the queries
for which the lineage has a probably
polynomial size obdd turns out to be the
same class for which they have a
polynomial size STG and they are
syntactically characterized as inversion
inversion pre queries and beyond that we
have a lesser understanding of the
border between those that have a
polynomial size F BDD or decision D D Ln
F and so said to not but we know a
separation for a very restricted class
and finally I talked about hierarchical
queries and just to explain the
hierarchical queries correspond
precisely to the border between P time
and sharpey heart but only for they're a
very restricted class of conjunctive
queries without Selvi joints not beyond
that good I know I'm running out of time
so I will stop
here and take me the question with the
obvious question is does it make sense
to take a inclusion/exclusion into the
motional accounting equal l based right
at you
I should avoid it conceptually you can
always do this you could imagine that a
magical our giri's will identify exactly
the original structure of ciphers of the
sentence over the proper propositional
sentence and do exactly the same
inclusion/exclusion but that is
practically being feasible and none I
mean right now you're waiting until you
have to rejoin components right and you
do they just a product of of the you
just take they the product to compute
the Sun right but you could imagine you
have two formulas that do have overlap
an argument just the same way I'll do it
you're doing it to the DP little base
version right could you really active
lf+
independent component component caching
you could instead say let's try to think
about more general way of separating
formulas they still have some overlap
that have a small overlap well if you
have a small rubber up that the only
option is to do the Shannon expansion on
the overlap and then do the B actual
layer component that is the only way to
deal with a small overlap but that still
force between the same framework so that
will not will not break this you cannot
try to include the exclusion of the
proposition eleven okay we can take this
offline